I AM JESSE WATTERS WITH
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
BRIAN KILMEADE,
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE, -- THIS IS
TAX BILL AND CONGRESS IS
KNEE-DEEP IN ANOTHER FIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP THINKS DEMOCRATS
DOWN FOR THE HOLIDAYS IN ORDER
TO DISTRACT FROM THE VERY
POPULAR JUST PAST PASS CUT.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS DO NOT LET
THIS HAPPEN, PASSING THE CR
BILL.
WE DO SEE IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM TO AT LEAST ALLOW A
VOTE.
AT LEAST ALLOW A VOTE ON
DREAMERS, WHICH WE THINK THAT WE
THE URGENCY OF IT.
SPEAK TO THE HOUSE IS NEARLY AT
A SHORT-TERM SPENDING BILL, THE
FIRST STEP IN A SHUT DOWN AT
MIDNIGHT TOMORROW.
>> Dana: NOT MUCH, KNOW WHEN
YOU HAVE MAJORITIES WITH THE
REPUBLICANS ABLE TO PASS IT IN
THE HOUSE.
I THINK THAT IT IS GOING TO PASS
IN THE SENATE.
I DO NOT THINK THAT THIS IS A
GREAT WAY TO GOVERN, WE GO
THROUGH THIS QUITE OFTEN.
BUT YOU HAVE A SPENDING BILL AND
THE GAME OF CHICKEN FOR WHO WILL
BE BLAMED FOR THE GOVERNMENT
HAPPEN.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
GET IT DONE, THE TICKING POINT
THEY ALREADY CONCEDED THAT THEY
WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT IN
DEADLINE WAS NOT UNTIL MARCH.
THEY HAVE SOME TIME.
>> Jesse: HE EXTENDED THE
IMMIGRATION OVERALL.
OKAY, SO, IF THEY DO SHUT IT
DOWN WHICH THEY WILL NOT, BUT IF
THEY DO, BRIAN, SOMEHOW, WILL IT
BE THE DEMOCRATIC SHUTDOWN,
BECAUSE ALWAYS REPUBLICANS GET
BLAMED >> Brian: BECAUSE THEY
ARE IN THE MAJORITY.
I HEARD NANCY PELOSI SAY THAT WE
ME?
WHICH IS TRUE, IF THEY GOT ON
IT'S LOOKING UNTIL WHAT?
JANUARY 19TH, THE LONGER THEY
COULD DO THAT, YOU ARE GIVING
LEADERSHIP THE CHANCE TO TELL
EVERYBODY WHERE THEY SPEND AS
OPPOSED TO MEMBERSHIP.
SO WHY CAN'T I GET EVERYTHING IN
ORDER STARTING MAY BE BEFORE
JANUARY 19TH TO START PUTTING
THINGS THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS AND DECIDING HOW WE ARE
GOING TO SPEND RATHER THAN WAIT
TILL THE LAST MINUTE AND GIVE IT
TO MITCH McCONNELL AND
PAUL RYAN.
>> Kimberly: AND MAKE THEM EAT
IT.
>> Jesse: WHY CAN'T THE
DEMOCRATS LET THE TAX CODE TO
MARINATE AND LET TRUMP TAKE A
VICTORY LAP?
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO REIN ON HIS
PARADE INTO THE SHUTDOWN?
IT IS SO MEAN OF THEM.
>> Kimberly: MEAN-SPIRITED AND
THE TIME OF CHRISTMAS GIVING.
IT DOES NOT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SPECIFICS, THEY ARE GOING TO
DO WHAT THEY CAN AND THE
POLITICS INVOLVED HERE.
IT IS POLITICAL BACK AND FORTH,
AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO LET
HIM HAVE THIS.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT THAT?
THEY WANT TO SAY THAT IT IS
TERRIBLE AND SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
ULTIMATELY, I WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU GUYS THAT I DO NOT THINK
THEY WILL SHUT IT DOWN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
LET'S SHUT IT DOWN OVER THE
HOLIDAY?
>> Jesse: WE HAVE TO STAY
UNTIL CHRISTMAS EVE.
>> Kimberly: LET'S COUNT ON
THAT NOT HAPPENING.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE TRYING TO
DIVERT ATTENTION FROM ALL THE
CORPORATE TAX CUTS WERE GOING TO
GO TO THE FAT CAT CEOs,
INSTEAD OF A BUNCH OF COMPANIES
ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHAT TO THE
>> Juan: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
DEMOCRAT SAID.
THAT IS THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THEY SAID.
>> Juan: I'M GOING TO FINISH
THE POINT, AND THEN YOU CAN
START WITH THE NONSENSE.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS TRUE.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU SEE TODAY IS
THAT A TONG OF THE COMPANY SAY
BECAUSE OF THE TAX CUTS WILL
WHICH MATCH WHICH WILL ENRICH
OUR TAX ERRORS, THIS WILL BE A
BONUS TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IT IS THE RESULTS OF THE FACT
THAT THESE COMPANIES MADE OUT
LIKE BANDITS FOR THE TAX DEAL.
THAT IS A FACT.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE AGAINST
PEOPLE GETTING THOUSAND DOLLAR
HAPPENING HERE, YOU HAVE THAT
THE VERY RICH GOT RICHER AND
THEY SAY, HERE'S A LITTLE BIT
FOR YOU, WHY DON'T YOU TAKE THIS
FOR YOU, WHY DON'T YOU TAKE THI
THIS --
>> Jesse: $1000 IS NOT A
LITTLE BIT.
>> Juan: IT REMAINS UNPOPULAR,
IF IT COMES TO A SHUT DOWN RIGHT
WHY DO I SAY THAT?
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
PUBLIC OPINION ON THEIR SIDE.
YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS WHO SAY,
LET'S PUMP UP MILITARY SPENDING
AND THE DEFICIT AND YET THEY
DON'T EVER SAY COMING HERE AS
NEW SOURCES OF REVENUE IN ORDER
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET.
ABOUT CUTTING SPENDING.
IF IT IS SO SARAH HUCKABEE
OF THE TOP PRIORITIES.
YOU CAN EXPECT WELFARE REFORM,
INFRASTRUCTURE, IMMIGRATION
REFORM, ALL WILL BE TOP OF MIND
AND SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
LOOKING AT AND TALKING ABOUT A
LOT OVER THE COURSE OF NEXT
YEAR.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE INGREDIENTS?
>> Dana: I THINK THAT ALL
THE MOST ON LEGISLATIVELY BEFORE
YOU HEAD INTO THE MIDTERM.
WITH THE THREE BIG THINGS THAT
THE PRESIDENT CAN CLAIM IN THE
TAX BILL YESTERDAY INCLUDING THE
DRILLING, WHICH IS AMAZING FOR
REPUBLICANS TO GET THROUGH,
WHERE DO YOU GO FROM THERE?
I THINK THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE SOME MESSAGING PROBLEMS ON
WELFARE REFORM.
IF THEY CAN COMMUNICATE IT IN A
WAY THAT SAYS, WE ARE WANTING TO
REFORM THE SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN
GET PEOPLE OUT OF A POVERTY
TRAP, AND THIS IS THE WAY THAT
WE WANT TO DO THAT.
THAT WOULD BE -- IT IS A GOOD
MESSAGE WHEN THE PROBLEM IS THAT
YOU JUST GAVE CORPORATIONS AND
FROM THE POOREST AMONG US, HOW
DARE YOU.
THAT IS A TOUGH MESSAGING THING.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY DO IT.
ON INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
DEMOCRATICS             DEMOCRAS
REALLY WANTED.
BUT THAT TAX BILL IS SUPPOSED TO
BE THE NEW REVENUE TO FUND THE
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
BUT BECAUSE I GOT ALL SCREWED UP
AND THEY BASICALLY HAD TO PAY
FOR THAT ON THE INDIVIDUAL SIDE
INSTEAD OF THE CORPORATE SIDE,
NOW WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO GET
THE MONEY?
THEY ARE FLOATING THE IDEA OF A
GAS TAX, DO YOU WANT TO HIT THEM
WHERE IT HURTS?
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC FOR THEM,
THE LAST ONE IN IMMIGRATION
REFORM, THAT IS THE MOST
PLAUSIBLE AND PROBABLY OUT OF
THOSE THREE THE MOST IMPORTANT.
I THINK THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE MEETING IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY ON THE SIDE, VERY LITTLE
SO IF YOU CAN GIVE THEM BORDER
SECURITY OR DACA.
THERE WAS REPUBLICANS THAT SAY,
YOU CAN BE FRUSTRATED, MITCH
McCONNELL, PUT UP THEIR HANDS.
I WILL TAKE THE SLINGS AND
ARROWS.
WILL BE A BAD MESSAGE EVEN
THOUGH IT IS NECESSARY.
ALL OF THESE REFORMS SHOULD BE
NECESSARY, BUT TO GO, OKAY, NOW
THAT'S GOING TO WELFARE FOR THE
POOR PEOPLE EVEN THOUGH YOU ARE
PERFORMING AT TO MAKE IT A
BETTER COUNTRY, IT WOULD BE NOT
>> Jesse: SO KIMBERLY, TO THE
POINT, TRADE THAT OFFER THE
WALL, DO YOU THINK THAT IS
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE AND BRING
SOMETHING TO DO TABLE.
YOU WANT THEM TO INCREASE BORDER
SOMETHING THAT IS MEANINGFUL.
THAT IS THE PRICE OF DOING
BUSINESS, WHETHER IT IS POLITICS
OR A FINANCIAL INDUSTRY,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HE WOULD
BE OPEN TO ANY REASONABLE ABOUT,
BECAUSE OF HIS HEIGHTENED
INTEREST AND DESIRE TO INCREASE
BORDER SECURITY.
A VERY BIG BANNER ITEM THAT HE
PROMISED DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
SO HE IS GOING THROUGH THE LIST,
HE IS CHECKING IT TWICE.
>> Jesse: [LAUGHS]
>> Kimberly: HE WILL FIND OUT
WHICH DEMOCRATS ARE NOT AIR
NICE.
I JUST MADE THAT UP.
>> Jesse: I LOVE THAT.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU THINK
IS NICE?
>> Juan: YES, IMMIGRATION.
ARGUMENT HAS SHIFTED AFTER WHAT
WE SAW IN VIRGINIA, EVEN ALABAMA
FOR THOSE ISSUES WERE FRONT AND
CENTER AND PEOPLE WERE LIKE, NO,
THAT IS NOT GOING TO PUSH ME
OVER THE LINE.
DONALD TRUMP'S SUCCESS, A LITTLE
THAT PAUL RYAN REALLY WANTS A
I'M TALKING ABOUT
SOCIAL SECURITY, MEDICARE, WHICH
ARE BIG SLICES OF THE FEDERAL
BUDGET.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID THAT HE
WILL NOT DO IT, BUT GUESS WHAT,
DANA, I THINK THAT IS WHAT TO
RYAN ONCE, A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS ONE.
THEY WANT TO PUSH THAT.
AND AS YOU GUYS ARE SAYING, I AM
SO PLEASED TO HEAR YOU SAY IT,
IT IS INSANITY RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
MOST AMERICANS SEE THIS AS A
GIVEAWAY TO THE RICH, THE TAX
BILL.
IF YOU COME BACK AND SAY, WE ARE
GOING TO PUMP UP DEFENSE
SPENDING AND SMACK DOWN THE
ELDERLY AND THE POOR, AND DON'T
FORGET THAT THEY HAVE YET TO
REMOVE DACA.
AND EVEN REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING,
THIS IS A PROBLEM BY JANUARY
JANUARY 1ST --
>> Dana: THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT SARAH SANDERS TALKED ABOUT
TODAY, BUT I KNOW THAT IT IS ON
THEIR MIND, WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THE OPIATE CRISIS.
TODAY AGAIN FOR THE SECOND YEAR
IN A ROW, WE HAVE THE CD TO SEE,
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
TELLING US THAT AMERICAN LIFE
EXPECTANCY IS GOING THE WRONG
THAT IS INCREASING THE DEATHS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR,
YOUNG MEN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS.
PATROL SAYS WE HAVE A PROBLEM
COMING OVER THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
I WILL SAY THIS, I THINK THAT IT
IS AN OVERSIMPLIFICATION TO SAY
THAT THE WHOLE THING IS A TAX
BREAK FOR THE RICH.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WITH MONEY
ARE COMPLAINING, THEY ARE NOT
GETTING THEIR BREAK THAT THEY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT CORPORATIONS
COME I WANT TO QUOTE
MITT ROMNEY, IT IS PEOPLE.
AND THEIR ENTRY-LEVEL JOBS IN
THOSE PLACES AND AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING PEOPLE BACK.
AND THE MOVIE INDUSTRY, OF ALL
THINGS IS GOING TO BENEFIT THE
MOST.
>> Dana: WILL THEY WRITE ANY
GOOD MOVIES SO?
>> Brian: I'M NOT SURE.
>> Juan: DID YOU JUST SAY THAT
THE RICH WERE SAYING THEY ARE
NOT GETTING ENOUGH.
>> Brian: THEY GET 2%.
37%- 3035%.
87% OF THE BENEFIT HAS BEEN
GOING TO THE RICH ON THE
CORPORATION'S COMMANDING GUYS
STILL WANT MORE.
>> Brian: CORPORATIONS ARE
MADE UP OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
MIDDLE-CLASS.
THE CORPORATIONS WHO ARE RICH
PEOPLE?
>> Juan: IF THEY CREATE JOBS
FOR THOSE PEOPLE, THAT WOULD BE
GREAT, BUT THIS IS ABOUT
AWARDING SHAREHOLDERS.
>> Brian: IF THEY ACT
RESPONSIBLY, THAT WOULD BE THE
ANSWER, BUT IF THEY ACT
RESPONSIBLY, THEY WILL GROW THE
COMPANY, THEY KNOW THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO GET IT AGAIN.
>> Juan: IF WE TRUST THE VERY
RICH, THEY WILL HELP US.
>> Jesse: HAS A POOR PERSON
EVER GIVING YOU A JOB, JUAN?
>> Kimberly: WHAT BRIAN IS
SAYING IS VERY IMPORTANT, YOU
KIND OF DEMONIZE THE
CORPORATE'S, BUT THEY ARE A
SUPPORT, WORKING IN STAFF,
ET CETERA, WHY DO YOU WANT TO
BEGRUDGE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING AND PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILY?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT!
SOME IMPROVEMENT AND RELIEF IS
BETTER THAN NONE AT ALL.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK THAT
CORPORATE PRODUCTS ARE AT A
HIGHER LEVEL?
YES THEY ARE.
MORE.
>> Kimberly: THE ARGUMENT IS
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE ON A
SITUATION THAT HAS BEEN
FORTUITOUS.
WHY NOT DO IT?
WHY NOT SPREAD IT AROUND FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS?